you know it's funny with these Hunger
Games books were first coming out I
thought Mockingjay was about someone
named J being made fun of that was like
cruise J why they making fun of J for J
and his years ago did in any case the
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1 so the
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1 is part 1
of 2 because if we've learned anything
is that the last book in a saga of books
Lee adapted to the big screen needs to
be two movies why not why not and in
Mockingjay part 1 Katniss is sorry
that's kind of a spoiler alert for the
last movie if you haven't seen the last
movie it's gonna kind of spoil the end
or no spoilers from walking J part 1 in
this video this is spoiler free for
Catching Fire
you get Katniss is hanging out in
district 13 because it was bombed to
back in the day but so people are
there and they're like this rebellion
and they've been waiting for someone a
figure a figure of Hope mocking and now
she's arrived it was one of the things I
liked about this movie this movie
ultimately is a huge departure from the
last two movies the first one is like
Battle Royale
second one was a better version of the
first one and now in this movie there's
no Hunger Games whatsoever it's about
propaganda and what I mean by that
is the Capitol is doing propaganda
against the freedom fighters and
districts their team to like save their
dicks and this is just this is what
dicks do so they're like well now we
have Katniss so we have to do propaganda
against them and show that she's a
symbol of hope you know it was actually
really cool
the last book has been made into two
movies in that it's not gonna have a
compression of really cool to see
for two hours sometimes there's some
downtime and you're like alright well
you guys can get moving now I get this
bonding moment at the lake but come on
there's a rebellion out there however I
still dug this movie because the
political intrigue was really cool I
like that I like political chess where
it's like God it's not just you know
firing guns and just storming the castle
they do a smear campaign you do a smear
campaign you don't really know where
everyone's coming from you kind of think
that through this put the whole
Hunger Games story at another level for
me I really got what people have been
freaking out about for the past few
years granted the bummer is this movie
has so many characters thrown at you
that no one really shines except cadiz
we're already on Katniss's side because
it's Jennifer Lawrence and everyone
loves her
Finnick the coolest character and
catching fires in the movie briefly just
one scene with Liam Hemsworth Gale I
forgot his name even it's a really tense
moment it's actually a really cool scene
has a lot of tension but I was like I
don't really
care that much about Gale to really give
a about him I like the intensity of
the scene that was really cool that if I
cared about Gale that would have been
compounded and this movie does suffer
from what the best of movies are going
to suffer from if you do something like
this which is take one book and make it
into two movies which is yeah it feels
like solid build up to what looks to be
a great finale but it's still the build
ups like getting into a hot rod and
going down oh no no no come on
start start doing yeah turning it off
going alright it starts it's good come
on let's go why are you still in the hot
run come on you're just like I'm going
to drive it I want it to go to the
destination you don't really get that I
mean even Harry Potter suffers from that
definitely Hallows part-2
awesome definitely Hallows part why I'm
still awesome in its own right but let's
be honest if I watch part one I'm going
right into part two which is probably
the point but as part one stands on its
own it's only really relevant if it's
with part two in the end The Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 1 I really dug it
it actually approaches the Hunger Games
world and story from another angle from
the other two movies and that put it up
on another level for me still love the
character Katniss there are a couple
moments roles like oh man I don't know
if I'm tearing up I'm just getting that
feeling but it was a really effective
moment I love the look behind the
curtain of what it takes to ultimately
run a rebellion against an evil empire
in a propaganda ish kind of way not just
guns blazing kind of way I will say The
Hunger Games Mockingjay part 1 is worth
buying on blu-ray so The Hunger Games
Mockingjay part 1 have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]